[Musik]
ich finde sehr gut das drastische
maßnahmen früh ergriffen werden ich
glaube an das objekt wie sie nicht her
ich denke ich muss immer abwägen sich
der gefahr die droht und die mit
abzuwenden will und den belastungen wie
man dafür in kauf nimmt
ich finde das sehr vernünftig noch
richtig weil irgendwo so können wir das
ganze in den griff bekommen
stimmen aus münchen unter brücken zu den
verschärften maßnahmen der bundesländer
gegen das corona virus waren das und
damit herzlich willkommen zum zdf
spezial
bleiben sie zu hause halten sie abstand
wegen corona anfang der woche war das
noch eine bitte ein appell doch mehr und
mehr wird dieser aufruf durch konkrete
verbote ersetzt
auch weil sich nicht alle bürger daran
halten so argumentiert zum beispiel
bayerns ministerpräsident
er hat deshalb für den freistaat bereits
gestern grundlegende ausgangs
beschränkungen beschlossen
und das obwohl die bundesländer und
bundeskanzlerin merkel eigentlich erst
morgen gemeinsam darüber entscheiden
wollten
wie die situation heute in münchen
aussieht berichtet christoph schneider
münchen innenstadt am vormittag vor dem
rathaus an dem sich sonst nicht nur an
wochenenden heerscharen von touristen
tummeln ist nichts los die
fußgängerzonen fast menschenleer
für die wenigen passanten sind die
verhängten ausgangsbedingungen richtig
und konsequent von der seiten ist in
ordnung und wichtig und es da ist der
schritt nicht gehen und also ich bin
froh dass es beschränkt worden ist weil
ich das gefühl hatte die letzten tage
dass sich die leute nicht genügend dran
gehalten haben die gestern vom
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten söder
landesweit ausgesprochenen ausgangs
beschränkungen bis zum dritten april
sie zeigen in münchen wirkung auf
straßen herrscht weitgehend ruhe
einsatzfahrzeuge der polizei sind
unterwegs beamte kontrollieren die
verordneten einschränkungen menschen
verlassen nur aus triftigen gründen ihre
wohnung kaufen ein oder gehen zur
apotheke über wenig kundschaft klagt die
marktfrau kann die beschränkungen aber
verstehen
es geht um die existenz auch jetzt muss
ich sofort hilfe beantragen
mittlerweile existieren kann ich
verstehe das ist zu die ausgangssperre
leider kommen musste ja weil die leute
sich nicht dran gehalten haben wir das
nicht eingesehen haben dass sie sich
abstand halten müssen zueinander mehr zu
hause bleiben sollen und das ist die
konsequenz jetzt davon
kreativ ist man in dieser münchner
gaststätte da lokale restaurants und
biergärten jetzt geschlossen sind bietet
man hier speisen zum mitnehmen an eine
notlösung um den betrieb am laufen zu
halten
ich denke jetzt mal so ein zwei tage das
einfach mal dass die leute jetzt auch
daheim bleiben
aber ich sag mal so eine pizza oder
pasta holen die sich dann schon wieder
zum mitnehmen von der gaststätte in der
innenstadt raus ansonst bevölkerte
isarufer auch hier ist nicht viel los
vereinzelt jogger familien gehen
spazieren und gassigänger abstand halten
und kontakt vermeiden in münchen hat es
heute geklappt was föderalismus bedeutet
wird aktuell so deutlich wie selten
es ist schwer überhaupt noch einen
überblick zu behalten denn in jedem
bundesland jeweils andere regeln gelten
im kampf gegen korona hinzu kommt was
gestern noch kalt kann morgen schon
wieder ganz anders aussehen
später in der sendung werden wir dazu
auch noch zuschauer fragen beantworten
erst mal schauen wir jetzt allerdings
nach niedersachsen wo die maßnahmen noch
nicht so streng sind wie in bayern
von dort berichtet wilhelm tacke die
lister meile eine beliebte
einkaufsstraße in hannover
ordnungsdienste der stadt kontrollieren
vor und in den geschäften die
sicherheitsabstände die polizei fährt
streife appelliert an die bürger
die botschaft scheint angekommen zu sein
vor den bäckereien lange schlangen bis
weit auf die straße hinaus alle sind
darauf bedacht den sicherheitsabstand zu
wahren habe ich vollstes verständnis für
einmal ist es für mich sicher und ich
denke auch für meine mitmenschen an
normalen samstagen ist der italiener an
der ecke ein beliebter treffpunkt
frühstücken cappuccino und prosecco
trinken heute die tische verweist er hat
schon jetzt wegen corona geschlossen und
ab 18 uhr gilt das für alle restaurants
cafés und gaststätten in niedersachsen
sind das richtig offenbar sind die leute
nicht vor selbst in der lage vernünftig
und solidarisch zu handeln und dann ich
finds schade dass es nur so geht aber
offenbar funktioniert es nicht anders
und das ist schon ungewohnt also sich
nicht mehr so mit freunden
in der kneipe treffen zu können oder mal
essen zu gehen das ist für mich ziemlich
schwierig für die armen gastwirte aber
im ergebnis finde ich es wichtig richtig
und halte es auch für die notwendigen
maßnahmen damit wir eben tatsächlich
jetzt durch die zeit kommen kneipenwirt
enzo for me and o hat bereits am
donnerstag freiwillig zu gemacht nachdem
er die ansprache der bundeskanzlerin
gehört hatte und man hat das immer noch
ein bisschen belächelt aber nach der
ansprache
für mich persönlich hat das dem bereich
wo ich gesagt habe ich muss mich und bei
den gästen die gäste schützen und am
sattel schließen kneipen und restaurants
zu reicht diese einschränkung oder wird
es neben bayern auch weitere
bundesländer geben die ausgangs
beschränkungen anordnen in diesen zeiten
ist vieles ungewiss und live
zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt der
ministerpräsident niedersachsens stephan
weil guten abend herr weil grüß gott
das heißt ja dass dieser samstag das
verhalten der bürger heute entscheidend
dafür ist ob die ministerpräsidenten
morgen härtere maßnahmen beschließen
oder nicht der samstag ist jetzt ja fast
vorbei wie ist ihr persönliches urteil
ich habe vorhin gerade den tagesbericht
unserer polizei gelesen
in niedersachsen hat es wirklich eine
spürbare verhaltensänderung gegeben und
zwar landesweit und insofern bin ich für
den heutigen tag ganz zufrieden aber das
ändert nichts daran werden wir morgen
miteinander sprechen werden dann werden
wir auch darüber reden was
wahrscheinlich noch notwendig sein wird
an welcher stelle auch immer aber für
heute merkt man die leute haben
verstanden um was es geht und das ist
sehr gut
am donnerstag haben sie noch gesagt sie
sind ganz klar gegen ausgangssperren hat
sich irgendetwas an ihrer haltung
geändert
nein nicht wirklich und auch die
bayerischen kollegen sprechen
klugerweise von ausgangs beschränkungen
denn es gibt einen sehr sehr langen
katalog von wie finde sehr not werden
ihren ausnahmen und wenn man diese
ausnahmen zusammenfasst dann merkt man
das ist substanziell ehrlich gesagt
nicht den ganz großen unterschied zu dem
macht was wir zum beispiel in
niedersachsen aber auch in anderen
ländern erleben
unter dem strich meine ich dass wir
derzeit in allen ländern eigentlich ein
ziemlich identisches schutzniveau haben
es gibt durchaus unterschiedliche
situationen in den unterschiedlichen
deutschen
region aber das niveau ist im kern
dasselbe nichtsdestotrotz haben bayern
und das saarland nun nicht warten wollen
und haben die drastischen
bewegungseinschränkungen früher ja
beschlossen
sind sie einverstanden mit diesem
alleingang also persönlich habe ich seit
beginn der krise immer großen wert
darauf gelegt dass wir versuchen so gut
wie möglich uns unter bund und 16
ländern miteinander abzustimmen damit
die bürgerinnen und bürger den alu chrom
den berechtigten eindruck haben dass wir
das gemeinsam meistern
diese wirklich schwierige aufgabe vor
der wir stehen und da hat sich
niedersachsen auch dran und deswegen
haben wir auch ganz bewusst gesagt
werden wir uns am sonntag miteinander
unterhalten dann wenn da am montag für
niedersachsen schauen ob wir weitere
entscheidungen zu treffen haben aber
nicht umgekehrt schon davor
glauben sie denn dass es morgen abend
eine einstimmige lösung mit der
bundeskanzlerin geben wird oder bleibt
das so ein bisschen beim flickenteppich
mit dem flickenteppich ist das so eine
sache ich sagte ja die ein länder nennen
es so die anderen ländern nennen das
anders aber im kern haben wir überall in
ganz deutschland wesentliche aufenthalts
beschränkungen es gibt viele orte an die
man nicht gehen darf es gibt
andererseits eine reihe von gründen auf
deren grundlage man dann hinaus genau
menschen müssen einkaufen müssen
arbeiten und sie sollen auch mal an die
frische luft kommen das ist in bayern
nicht anders als in niedersachsen
egal was morgen entschieden wird schon
jetzt greift der staat ja massiv ins
privatleben der menschen ein in die
persönliche freiheit wie lange hält eine
gesellschaft das denn aus ich hoffe dass
wir alle gemerkt dass das jetzt hier
kein sprint ist sondern dass wir einen
etwas längeren atem brauchen und dass
alle wissen es hängt jetzt wirklich von
unserer disziplin ab ob deutschland
durch diese krise krise gut durchkommen
kann
das ist anders als jeder andere krise
die ich bis jetzt erlebt habe es sind im
kern an unserem eigenen verhalten von
jedem und jeder einzelnen nach den
erfahrungen des heutigen tages und auch
schon zunehmend in den letzten tagen bin
ich eigentlich recht zuversichtlich dass
es inzwischen fast alle begriffen haben
und die ist immer noch nicht begriffen
haben wie wird man möglicherweise auch
mit hilfe der polizei daran erinnern
müssen
vielen dank
für das gespräch während sich die
ministerpräsidenten hier in deutschland
also morgen noch sortieren was
drastische maßnahmen angeht haben andere
länder in europa längst landesweite
ausgangssperre beschlossen
italien hat den anfang gemacht aber auch
in frankreich und österreich
beispielsweise wurden sperren
beschlossen wie sich das leben dort
seitdem verändert hat zeigt christine es
nach italiens hauptstadt rom wirkt wie
ausgestorben
das von der krise am stärksten
betroffene land in europa hat als erstes
die ausgangssperre verhängt beliebte
plätze wie die piazza navona oder das
pantheon sind seither menschenleer
die disziplin mit der die römer die
ausgangssperre respektieren ist groß im
kampf gegen den gemeinsamen feind corona
virus rücken sie zusammen
es ist richtig so für die gesundheit ist
es wichtig das ist alles normal
ich denke das ist reine routine in
diesen tagen dieser müssen wir uns
unterziehen das geht in ordnung
leider ist es ein dunkler moment traurig
wir müssen das alle zusammen angehen und
zu hause bleiben so lange wie möglich
solidarität trotz starker einschränkung
15 tage soll der ausnahmezustand gelten
doch wegen der noch immer hohen zahl der
korona ansteckungen will regierungschef
zusätze konnte die ausgangssperre bis
nach dem dritten april verlängern
diese maßnahme sei unvermeidbar so der
regierungschef
seit montag dieser woche gilt in ganz
österreich eine ausgangs beschränkung
bilder von heute vormittag zeigen es ist
fahrt in wien bundeskanzler sebastian
kurz appelliert immer wieder an die
bevölkerung zu hause zu bleiben
es sei denn man müsse zur arbeit gehen
es gilt nur notwendige besorgungen
erledigen und anderen menschen helfen
die auf unterstützung angewiesen sind
ein besuch im kaffeehaus das geht nicht
mehr
es ist es nicht aber ich denke jetzt
gerade hier in österreich ist ja alles
was regierungs mäßig macht hier das
wetter glaube ich ist es super manager
die politische vorgabe lautet nur die
unmittelbare versorgung aufrechterhalten
viele wiener gehen nachdenklich damit um
ein gefühl von zusammenhalt unter
menschen bei allen eigentlich die ich
kenne die hoffnung dass es ein
denkprozess auslösten oder ausgelöst
habt was nach kona wenn wir es schaffen
kommen könnte ein landesweiter minimal
betrieb der allerdings durch die
frühlingssonne in den letzten tagen
durchbrochen wurde
denn die wiener zog es raus in den
berater viele menschen ohne
sicherheitsabstand das ist eine
missachtung der ausgangs beschränkung so
schreitet die polizei inzwischen ein
wenn sich gruppen auf der straße bilden
spaziergänge sind zwar weiterhin erlaubt
aber möglichst allein
zudem hat bundeskanzler kurz an diesem
wochenende angeordnet dass die ausgangs
beschränkung verlängert wird bis
ostermontag seit dienstag dieser woche
gilt in frankreich bleibt zu hause
staatschef emanuel makro hat eine
strikte ausgangssperre verhängt es
herrscht einsamkeit in paris keinerlei
betrieb auf den plätzen und straßen
nur wenn es unbedingt nötig ist sollen
die menschen das haus verlassen
ein spaziergang an der frischen luft ist
kein grund um rauszugehen
jeder muss einen passierschein dabei
haben auf dem muss vermerkt sein warum
man unterwegs ist
die polizei kontrolliert strikt bei
verstößen drohen 135 euro bußgeld wir
können uns an die ausgangssperre
gewöhnen aber man kommt an einen punkt
an dem man es satt hat wir müssen
rausgehen und frische luft schnappen
wir versuchen es früh am tag zu machen
so dass wir nicht in direkten kontakt
mit anderen leuten kommen
ich arbeite seit sechs uhr morgens die
komplette stadt ist leer
es ist wirklich niemand unterwegs
die menschen versuchen die regeln
einzuhalten es funktioniert allerdings
macht es uns sorgen dem wir wissen nicht
ob die ausgangssperre verlängert wird
seit diesem wochenende gilt sogar noch
eine verschärfung der maßnahmen die
stadt sperrt die safer komplett ab
eigentlich hat präsident makro die
ausgangssperre auf 15 tage angesetzt
doch über eine verlängerung wird bereits
debattiert
unser korrespondent in paris thomas weil
da hat die situation in frankreich im
blick herr weil die freiheit der
franzosen wird stark eingeschränkt
niemand weiß so richtig wie lange das so
bleiben wird wie wird das in der
bevölkerung akzeptiert also die straßen
an diesem ersten wochenende der
ausgangssperre in paris waren deutlich
leerer als wir das in den tagen zuvor
gesehen haben
die wenigen menschen die auf der straße
waren haben deutlich mehr abstand
eingehalten voneinander und laut
umfragen ist eine mehrheit der franzosen
der meinung dass dieser kurs der
regierung gerichtet ist dass man ihn
unterstützen müsse in der
nationalversammlung wird an diesem
wochenende ein gesetz debattiert dass
der regierung erlauben soll künftig per
dekret noch schärfere maßnahmen zu
verhängen man rechnet auch da mit einer
großen unterstützung allerdings gibt es
auch einige kritische stimmen von
abgeordneten beispielsweise oder auch
von menschenrechtlern die sagen es ist
nicht ganz genau klar nach welchen
kriterien denn dann irgendwann
entschieden wird wann diese massive
einschränkung bürgerlicher freiheiten
denn wieder aufgehoben wird
wie streng wird denn überprüft ob die
verbote auch eingehalten werden
als sie die kontrollen sind streng der
innenminister hat angekündigt sie auch
noch weiter verschärfen zu wollen
man veröffentlicht bilder von drohnen
wie man sie bislang nur in china gesehen
hat die dabei helfen sollen die
unterstützen sollen mehrere tausend
strafzettel sind hier im land bereits
verteilt worden und gestern zum beispiel
hat die polizei die pariser bahnhöfe
kontrolliert weil viele menschen die
stadt verlassen wollten aufs land fahren
wollten sie ihren familien etwa und das
ist nicht möglich nach der
ausgangssperre
und diese leute wurden von der polizei
dann zurückgeschickt das ziel ist ja
dass ich weniger menschen mit dem virus
infizieren zeigen die maßnahmen denn
schon
wirkungen was das angeht also vor einer
knappen viertelstunde hat das
gesundheitsministerium neue zahlen
veröffentlicht danach sind allein in den
vergangenen 24 stunden
112 menschen mit dem corona virus
verstorben
die behörden und auch die regierung
haben von anfang an gesagt dass es zeit
brauchen werde
dass es dauern werde bis man eine umkehr
dort möglicherweise sehen kann
darum gehen viele hier auch davon aus
dass die zahlen erst mal noch weiter
ansteigen werden und dass die
ausgangssperre am ende über die 14 tage
hinaus verlängert wird
wie ist denn aktuell die situation in
den krankenhäusern die ist recht
unterschiedlich es gibt einige regionen
in denen sie recht prekär ist zb in der
grenzregion zu deutschland da sind
einige krankenhäuser inzwischen über
ihre grenzen hinaus gekommen
die armee verteilt dort kranke mit
flugzeugen mit hubschraubern auf andere
teile des landes hier in paris kommen
krankenhäuser inzwischen auch an ihre
grenze man erwartet dass auch dass sich
in den kommenden tagen und wochen noch
deutlich verschärfen wird
vielen dank thomas walde für das
gespräch auch bei uns in deutschland ist
der alltag schon jetzt eingeschränkt je
nach bundesland in unterschiedlichem maß
viele geschäfte sind geschlossen
spielplätze sind gesperrt und in vielen
bundesländern dürfen nun auch
restaurants und cafés nicht mehr für die
gäste öffnen
doch beschränkungen alleine helfen nicht
sie müssen auch eingehalten werden wie
das kontrolliert wird zeigt wie jeder
menge
normalerweise ist der marktplatz in
saarbrücken samstags voll mit menschen
aber normal ist hier gerade nichts seit
gestern nacht 0 uhr ausgangs
beschränkungen wie restaurants
geschlossen vor die tür darf nur wer
einen dringenden grund hat einkaufen
gehört dazu mit abstand halten und
gespenstig es ist merkwürdig und ich bin
froh wenn ich dann wieder nach hause
gehen kann weil man fühlt sich ein
bisschen verunsichert wir haben uns
immer hier getroffen haben markt und
das ist alles wie ausgestorben das
spiegelt so ein bisschen die
lebenssituation wieder wenn man noch
nicht krank ist dass man so das gefühl
hat dass alles ganz normal und
gleichzeitig weiß dass das gar nicht ist
die leute sollen zu hause bleiben
ordnungsamt und polizei kontrollieren es
sind drastische einschränkende maßnahmen
aber notwendige sagt der saarländische
ministerpräsident die menschen hier
hätten des corona virus zu lang nicht
ernst genommen die zahl der
krankheitsfälle im saarland steigt
exponentiell an führende wissenschaftler
auch hier im saarland sagen uns dass
wird am 23 märz bei 1000 liegen und am
30 märz bei 10.000 das zeigt man muss
jetzt handeln in der führungs und
lagezentrale der saarländischen polizei
laufen alle notrufe ein
bis heute vormittag gab es etwa 20
verstöße gegen die ausgangs
beschränkungen bei denen die
landespolizei eingreifen musste wer den
maßnahmen nicht nachkommt begeht eine
straftat ist droht ein bußgeld bis
25.000 euro in den allermeisten fällen
waren die leute einsichtig wenn sie
aufgefordert wurden auseinander zu gehen
nach hause zu gehen das haben sie auch
gemacht wir haben lediglich in einem
fall in einer so genannten corona party
in einem haus eine etwas schwierigere
situationen gehabt aber die danach
entsprechend klare ansage auch
entsprechend befolgt wurde hat natürlich
auch eine strafanzeige zur konsequenz
die beamten der bundespolizei sind für
die kontrollen an den grenzen zuständig
sie konzentrieren sich auf die großen
übergänge an den autobahnen wie hier an
der goldenen bremm 16 kleine
grenzübergänge sind mittlerweile für den
normalen verkehr geschlossen
wir wollen allerdings dafür sorge tragen
da werden wir auch für sorge tragen dass
rettungsdienste
hier geht es um menschenleben diesseits
vom jenseits der grenze diese grenze
nach wie vor passieren können deswegen
wird es keine betonklötze oder ähnliches
geben sondern wir hoffen er
mal nach wie vor auf die vernunft der
bürgerinnen und bürger in den kommenden
wochen wird sich zeigen ob kontrollen
und einschränkungen bei der eindämmung
des corona virus helfen und live
zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt der
innenminister baden württemberg thomas
strobl
guten abend herr strobl guten abend und
grüß gott frau zimmermann
herr strobl wie stellen sie denn in
baden württemberg sicher dass die neuen
maßnahmen beachtet werden
die neuen maßnahmen war werden beachtet
es ist wirklich eine andere welt ich war
heute selber in der frühe auf dem
heilbronner wochenmarkt den ich seit
vielen jahrzehnten kenne unterwegs die
stadt war fast menschenleer und autofrei
und die wenigen die unterwegs waren
haben sich außerordentlich diszipliniert
und rücksichtsvoll und verhalten das mag
auch am schlechten wetter gelegen haben
dass so wenige unterwegs waren aber wir
haben jetzt in baden württemberg sehr
klare regeln und wir kontrollieren das
auch in baden württemberg unterstützen
500 polizistinnen und polizisten des
polizeipräsidiums einsatz also
bereitschaftspolizei unsere präsidien in
der kontrolle der neuen regelungen
und das ist in ihrem beitrag ja schon
erwähnt worden der bußgeldrahmen ist
hoch es geht nicht um 25 euro bußgeld
sondern der bußgeldrahmen geht bis
25.000 euro und es sind haftstrafen
gefängnisstrafen möglich also klare
regeln eine konsequente überwachung
durch die polizei und auch ein
entsprechender bußgeldrahmen und das
hoffe ich auch eine zunehmende einsicht
bei den menschen hat schon einen
bewusstseinswandel bewirkt wir haben
eine neue lage
die freiheit der menschen wird ja schon
jetzt massiv eingeschränkt und da fragen
sich manche bürger wo soll das noch
hinführen
das stimmt das sind bereits massive
einschränkungen der freiheit
der bewegungsfreiheit aber etwa auch
wenn sie einmal an unsere unternehmen
unsere familienbetriebe an die
wirtschaft denken das ist aber notwendig
gewesen wir hatten in den letzten tagen
leider zu viele uneinsichtige und ich
möchte dass einmal deutlich sagen wir
haben jetzt sind baden-württemberg 23
tote heute zu beklagen
die meisten davon sind ältere menschen
im alter zwischen 67 und 94 jahren und
es geht einfach darum dass wir unsere
eltern und unsere großeltern schützen
und ihr haben alle eine verantwortung
und als wir feststellen mussten
das sehen nicht alle ein es gibt zu viel
sorglosigkeit haben wir die maßnahmen
verschärfen müssen um einfach schutz für
ältere menschen auch aufzubauen das ist
notwendig gewesen und wir werden das
jetzt in den nächsten tagen prüfen sind
weitere verschärfungen notwendig oder
nicht ich bin ganz sicher wir werden das
miteinander durch stehen wir sind ein
starkes volk wir haben ein gutes
gesundheitssystem wir haben eine gute
verwaltung und vielleicht darf ich auch
mal zum anlass nehmen all denen die
wirklich teilweise rund um die uhr bis
zur physischen erschöpfung arbeiten die
medizinischen bereich im pflegebereich
aber auch bei unseren polizistinnen und
polizisten danke zu sagen
absolut danke sagen das ist wichtig und
der schutz steht natürlich im
vordergrund trotzdem möchte ich noch
einmal zurück auf den punkt zuvor
nun ist auch die frage trotzdem wie
lange kann eine freie gesellschaft
solche maßnahmen verkraften oder solange
es notwendig ist und schauen sie wenn
ich heute noch einmal das bild in meiner
heimatstadt halbrund nehme menschenleere
straßen dort wo keine sozialen kontakte
mehr im öffentlichen raum stattfinden
können ja die infektionen in dem maße
nicht mehr übertragen werden deswegen
hoffe ich das wird aber einige tage
dauern
dass die infektions kurve sich abflacht
wir nicht diesen peak bekommen und wenn
die maßnahmen wirken dann müssen wir
klug
prüfen wo können wir das wieder etwas
lockern
ohne das natürlich wird dann wieder zu
viele infektionen bekommen
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen dass
muss ich leider klar sagen das wird
keine sache sein die uns einige tage
einige wochen einige monate beschäftigt
sondern ich vermute es wird um ein zwei
jahre gehen
das ist die wahrheit nämlich bis zu dem
zeitpunkt wo wir entweder einen
impfstoff zur immunisierung gegen korona
haben oder eben ein medikament das die
folgen dieser krankheit entsprechend
lindert oder eben beides auch da bin ich
zuversichtlich dass das gelingen wird
aber das wird noch einige zeit in
anspruch nehmen herr strobl ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen und wünsche ihnen und
ihren zuschauern einen guten
sonntagmorgen
vielen dank gerade in krisenzeiten
suchen menschen halt in ihrem glauben
doch die korona krise trifft auch die
kirchen moscheen und synagogen in
deutschland wegen der ansteckungsgefahr
sind gottesdienste und gemeinsame gebete
nicht mehr erlaubt so wie hier in der
evangelischen johanneskirche in berlin
frohnau
dort wurde alles für einen keimfreien
gottesdienst vorbereitet gesangsbücher
desinfiziert doch dann die ansage von
oben absagen
wir werden die menschen nach hause
schicken in dem gedanken dass unser
dienst an den schwachen in der
gesellschaft in diesen tagen darin
besteht zu verzichten und eben auch auf
diese versammlungen hier zu verzichten
so muss der fahrer nun
gottesdienstbesuchern die traurige
botschaft überbringen
und so geht es gerade vielen gemeinden
in deutschland was das für kirche und
gläubige bedeutet möchte ich mit udo
bands besprechen weihbischof hier in
mainz und ich freue mich sehr dass sie
heute hier ist ein zunehmend vor
zimmermann
herr benz jetzt sind die gottesdienste
abgesagt fallen aus gibt es irgendwelche
alternativangebote das ist für die
gläubigen sehr schwer weil das
zusammenkommen das zusammensein für den
glauben etwas ganz wesentliches und
wichtig es ist
wir haben das bei vielen kritischen
krisensituationen erlebt wie die
menschen in die kirche strömen zum beten
zum singen um sich gegenseitig halt und
solidarität zu versichern
das ist jetzt nicht möglich wir wollen
aber als kirchen natürlich auf ganz
andere weise versuchen bei den menschen
nah dran so sein präsenz zu zeigen nähe
sozusagen auf distanz so ambivalent das
ist dass es wie die quadratur des
kreises
aber es haben sich in den ersten tagen
so seit letzter woche ganz viele
aktivitäten und initiativen entwickelt
livestreaming von gottesdiensten die
jetzt initiiert werden allmählich
entwickeln wir digitale formen der
kommunikation chaträume in den
seelsorger stattfinden kann
alternative andachten die auch junge
menschen interessieren und die sie
wahrnehmen
wir leben uns also als digitale kirche
in dieser situation wir erleben uns aber
auch als analogen kirche neu wenn ich
das so sagen darf
dazu gehört dass die seelsorgerinnen und
seelsorger jetzt präsent ansprechbar
sein müssen vor allen dingen über das
telefon
gerade die alten menschen die keinen
zugang zum internet haben denen es
schwerfällt mit digitalen medien
umzugehen
die brauchen diese nähe die möglichkeit
der ansprache über das telefon
gebrauchen fernsehgottesdienst radio
gottesdienste diese analogen dinge aber
für den menschen ist zum beispiel jetzt
auch wichtig ich spüre dass und bekomme
ganz viel rückmeldung gebetsinitiative
dass man im gebet zu hause sich
verbunden weiß solidarisch weiß mit
vielen jeden abend die evangelische
kirche die katholischen bistümer um 19
uhr 1930 läuten die glocken man stellt
eine kerze ins fenster
man betet zu hause und weiß ich bin zwar
für mich und trotzdem mit den anderen
gemeinsam zusammen und geht ja nicht
alles digital
was ist zum beispiel mit solchen
ja dinge wie beerdigungen taufen oder
hochzeiten
das war natürlich sehr schmerzhaft für
die menschen als sie in den vergangenen
tagen von uns gesagt bekamen gibt fahrer
die seelsorgerin seelsorger bescheid
geben mussten dass in den nächsten
wochen keine taufen und keine traum
stattfinden können
da war vieles geplant vieles vorbereitet
hinter diesen feiern steckt ja auch sehr
viel rahmenbedingungen unter denen man
feiert aber wir haben gespürt dass die
menschen verständnis dafür haben wenn zu
feiern ohne die entsprechenden
möglichkeiten zu feiern und wer ganz
schwierigen auflagen das ist nicht
feiern
ich bin sehr froh dass es dieses
verständnis gibt und dass das verschoben
wird verlegt wird viel schwieriger ist
die situation bei beisetzungen bei
beerdigungen abschied nehmen können ist
für die menschen etwas ganz wesentliches
in ihrer trauerarbeit wie ist das
möglich im kleinen kreis wer kann dazu
kommen wer darf nicht dabei sein da
hoffe ich schon da erlebe ich auch dass
die seelsorger sehr eng in der
abstimmung mit den beerdigungsinstitut
in den einzelnen fällen sehr
verantwortlich umgehen und da hoffe ich
mir auch dass wir möglichkeiten in den
kommenden wochen haben das gut zu
gestalten von den äußeren auflagen her
der weihbischof werden das ganz
herzlichen dank dass sie heute hier bei
uns im studio zu gast waren sehr gern
lehrer die straßen werden desto enger
wird es in manchen wohnungen zum
beispiel für familien
seit einer woche sind deutschlandweit
schulen und kitas geschlossen die kinder
sind also zu hause den ganzen tag das
kann eltern an ihre grenzen bringen und
weitere ausgangs beschränkung würden die
situation noch verschärfen was kommt da
auf uns zu die nächsten wochen
wie fühlt sich das an wenn die neuen
maßnahmen gegen korona nicht mehr neu
sind wenn sie zum alltag werden gerade
familien stehen vor herausforderungen
eva schiller berichtet
es ist eine herausforderung für die
ganze familie
seit fast zwei wochen schon steht paul
unter quarantäne sein klassenlehrer hat
sich mit dem corona virus infiziert also
brüte der 16 jährige jetzt alleine über
vector rechnung mache jetzt nicht so ein
lehrer außerdem immer fragen kann oder
auch ich glaube meine eltern meine
eltern können es jetzt auch nicht so gut
aber weil das ist schon ein sehr
kompliziertes thema und deswegen für das
ein bisschen blöd wäre für mich jetzt
die ganzen stadt zu hören
mutter regina becker versucht zu helfen
so gut es eben geht
klar es gibt es internet es gibt alle
möglichen hilfestellungen aber keiner
der hier sitzt und fragt kann ich jetzt
nicht immer beantworten ganz klar
szenen die sich derzeit häufig
abspielenden deutschen familien regina
becker hat noch zwei töchter denen zu
hause die decke auf den kopf fällt
kinder notdürftig betreuen nebenbei
irgendwie arbeiten jetzt alltag für
viele eltern regina becker hat glück als
qualitäts prüferin kann sie im home
office arbeiten in der jetzigen
situation dürften wir alle ohne große
umschweife von zu hause arbeiten dann
ist schriftlich auch vor gassen erst
mehr bekommen wenn der husten schnupfen
hast ruf an bleibt zu hause kein problem
regina beckers partner arbeitet in einer
anderen stadt sie ist auf sich allein
gestellt die großeltern in die betreuung
einbinden kommt für sie nicht in frage
es gilt jetzt sicherheitsabstand zu
wahren
die lebensmittel bleiben vor der tür wie
gehts ja ich hab dir essen mitgebracht
spielen denn papa auch gut bilden also
ich will nicht daran schuld sein wenn
meine eltern jetzt sterben würden oder
sie ins krankenhaus müssten sie mir und
ich dann ein schlepper deswegen sogar zu
hause und das war's dann irgendwie die
nächsten wochen überstehen sich von tag
zu tag hangeln das versucht die familie
aber die große frage ist wie wird es
weitergehen
nicht was kommt du weißt nicht ob
herbst die sache zu ende ist weiß nicht
ob es im juli zu ende ist du kannst
nicht planen
das ist furchtbar dazu noch die sorge
vor ersten symptomen es ist die
ungewissheit auf allen ebenen die auf
familien lastet und das wollen wir
weiter vertiefen mit dem
diplom-psychologen dietmar langer guten
abend verlängert
zimmermann herr lange eltern und kinder
zusammen in einer wohnung und das den
ganzen tag was macht das mit familien ja
es ist natürlich einmal die sorge dass
bei ihm viel mehr zu sehen sorge um das
wohlergehen und die gesundheit der
angehörigen auch um die eigene familie
aber letztendlich wenn wir uns die
gesamtsituation anschauen das ist ein
absolutes novum wir haben bisher in
einer noch relative sicherheit
kontinuität stabilität gelebt und das
ist jetzt alles mehr oder weniger
schlagartig weg und wir wissen gar nicht
wie es weitergeht wie das prozedere ist
es gibt ideen und das ist für uns sehr
sehr belastend für zu verunsicherungen
natürlich auch letzter nicht stress und
das haben wir dann eben auch in der
familie kinder reagieren darauf die sind
ja wie seismografen regelrecht und und
spiegeln dann den stress den wir ja auch
haben die unsicherheit dann auch wieder
das kann natürlich zu konflikten führen
und in in der familie zwischen den
geschwistern zu reizbarkeit ja damit
muss man erstmal zurechtkommen wenn
jetzt eine ausgangs beschränkung oder
sogar eine ausgangssperre länger gilt
wie kann das gut gehen wie verhalten
sich eltern am besten
das wichtigste ist möglichst viel an dem
gewohnten beizubehalten was machbar ist
ja also jetzt nicht sich kommt völlig
aufzugeben sondern sagen die routinen
die mir geholfen haben die mehr struktur
geben also wirklich schlafenszeiten
essenszeiten oder wir haben den schüler
gesehen lernzeit noch eins sein genauso
wie eine freizeit auch wenn ich mich im
gleichen haus zu einer gleichen wohnung
bewegen und dann ist noch ein wichtiger
punkt auch wir leben zwar eng zusammen
aber wir haben auch ein bedürfnis nach
privatheit das heißt auch in einer
engeren wohnung sich räume schaffen
rückzugsmöglichkeiten zu schaffen den
anderen auch mal zu lassen
wir sind ja manchmal auch im urlaub eng
zusammen aber da haben wir uns
entschlossen und das ist das was uns
jetzt stress macht wir haben keine
entscheidungsfreiheit mehr und deswegen
sollten wir in unserem privaten leben
und diese kleine entscheidungs räume
auch geben wann habe ich kontakt und
wann david mich auch mal zurückziehen
wie erkläre ich den kindern was da
gerade passiert
es gibt ein bisschen auf das alter an
ich denke die grundschulkinder haben
schon viel mitbekommen wir können uns
gemeinsam sendungen noch angucken die
auch kindgerecht sind wo das erklärt
wird darüber diskutieren
das gleiche gilt natürlich für ältere
kinder bei den kleinen ist es
letztendlich so die denken ganz
praktisch ja welche möglichkeiten habe
ich ihm hier und jetzt zu handeln das
ist was aus dem kleines kind an ein
kindergartenkind interessiert es kann
nicht mehr in den kindergarten gehen
aber was können wir zu hause machen wir
können zu hause auch abenteuer spieler
machen wir können von meinetwegen vom
sessel zur couch hüpfen also es gibt
viele möglichkeiten auch im finde ich
sehr interessant was ich so im internet
tut es ist eine phase wo wir auch
kreativ sein können und uns auf dieser
ebene auch mal begeben können erklären
kann ich einem ganz kleinen kind das
nicht und ich würde auch jetzt nicht
alles auf alles auf den tisch legen das
erzeugt nur noch mehr angst wichtig ist
zu beruhigen ja dass wir sagen wir
kommen da durch wir kommen da gemeinsam
durch das ist das wichtigste gerade für
die kleinen kinder
vielen dank dietmar langer für ihre
einschätzung die situation ändert sich
täglich muss jeden tag neu bewertet
werden strengere ausgangs beschränkungen
könnten also morgen auch für andere
bundesländer verkündet werden das
verunsichert und wirft viele fragen auf
auch bei ihnen zu hause
wir haben einige dieser fragen gesammelt
und möchten sie jetzt hier im studio
beantworten und dafür ist sarah attacke
bei mir leiterin unserer redaktion recht
und justiz erst mal vielen dank dass du
hier bist sehr gerne und wir können uns
jetzt mal die erste frage an und zwar
geht es da um ausgangs beschränkung und
die kommt aus hannover
aus welchen gründen darf ich das haus
noch verlassen
also eine ganz grundlegende frage
stellen sich jetzt aktuell ganz viele
weil bayern angefangen hat und es kann
natürlich gut sein dass weitere kommunen
und länder folgen
aber es kommt immer darauf an was die
stadt oder die kommunen der klemme oder
das bundesland in der liebe was die
beschließen was die sagen was notwendig
ist
man kann aber ganz grundsätzlich sagen
es ist ein sehr starker eingriff in
unsere freiheit und deswegen wird es
vorerst dieses absolute nicht mehr die
wohnung verlassen nicht geben
es wird immer die auflage sein man soll
sich in der wohnung aufhalten aber man
kann zum supermarkt gehen man kann
seinen hund spazieren führen man kann
auch joggen gehen weil es ist die
immunologen sagen ja auch man soll
sportlich aktiv sein frische luft ist
wichtig man kann mit den kindern
spazieren geht in kleinen gruppen was
verhindert werden soll also sinn und
zweck der maßnahme ist ja das ist nicht
ausufert dass wir nicht wegen des
schönen wetters das jetzt kommen kann
dann mit 10 15 20 leuten zusammen im
garten sitzen und grillen das soll es
nicht geben
aber ist wird weiter möglich sein auch
die frage kam auch zu den pferden zu
fahren oder zur arbeit zu fahren schauen
wenn man auf die nächste frage
ich hatte eine frage und zwar muss ich
mich auf dem weg zur arbeit ausweist
so ist das ja zum beispiel schon in
frankreich genau also dass da kommt auch
wieder darauf an was das bundesland dass
gerade die ausgangs beschränkungen
verhängt hatte die ausgangssperre
verhängt hat was das vorsieht
in der regel ist es so dass die
verordnung dann schon vorsieht dass man
wenn man wenn man rausgeht und triftigen
grund hat man ihn auch nachweisen kann
also das wirklich dass der nächst
gelegene supermarkt ist oder bei der
arbeit muss man auch sagen hier ist mein
dienstausweis oder ich habe eine
bescheinigung vom arbeitgeber ich muss
diesen weg wirklich fahren
vielen dank zara tucker dass du diese
fragen für uns heute beantwortet hast
die theater sind dicht konzerte abgesagt
und auch der museumsbesuch muss
ausfallen kurzum vieles das spaß macht
das plötzlich verboten
die kulturbranche steht still und
irgendwie doch nicht denn parallel
explodiert das kunst- und kulturangebot
im internet künstlers trieben dort
plötzlich ihre konzerte autorenlesungen
und sogar der besuch im museum ist
digital möglich falls ihnen also zu
hause die decke auf den kopf fällt
vielleicht wäre das hier was für sie
verwaiste konzertsäle brachliegende
bühnen geschlossene bibliothek kultur in
zeiten der koran virtuell können viele
häuser weiter besucht werden schlendern
sie durch die vatikanischen museen oder
wenn ihnen das passende erscheint
erforschen sie einen antiken friedhof
wer der liebe zu toten objekten nicht
entsagen will europa bietet über 50
millionen artefakte und sterile online
ausstellungen zb zur europäischen
festkultur mit viel zu eng stehenden
menschenmassen und natürlich beerdigung
johan holten direktor der kunsthalle
mannheim stellt auf twitter jeden tag
ein werk seiner sammlung vor
begonnen hat er mit einem klassischen
risikopatienten noch mehr kunst wartet
in der digitalen kunsthalle von
zdfkultur vielleicht bringen sie ludwig
van beethoven oder die felix nussbaum
ausstellung auf andere gedanken
musik gibt es natürlich auch jeden abend
stream der pianist igor levit ein
hauskonzert und der rbb überträgt kamen
aus einer gespenstisch leeren staatsoper
liebestod stadt lungen versagen
die touristik
eine fortsetzung ist dennoch nicht zu
erwarten zur erklärung genügt der blick
in den kuscheligen orchestergraben die
berliner philharmoniker sind bereits
weit ihre digitale konzerthalle ist
prall gefüllt mit archivaufnahmen und
der zugang für die kommenden wochen
kostenlos
überall werden gelesen gestreamte
podcast and eröffnen sich chancen auf
neue digitale formate kann das netz den
besuch vor ort ersetzen oder kommen die
menschen jetzt auf die verrückte idee
selbst kreativ zu werden und das war es
von diesem zdf spezial
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit der quiz
champion und wir verabschieden uns mit
einem moment der solidarität
applaus für das medizinische personal
aufgenommen heute abend in hannover
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke an das pflegepersonal an alle
ärzte rettungskräfte
supermarktmitarbeiter eltern im
home-office verständnisvolle chefs
wissenschaftler die müllabfuhr lehrer
die ihre schüler mit aufgaben versorgen
helfende nachbarn
wir sagen danke an jede und jeden die
die soziale distanz waren die damit dem
virus den kampf ansagen
es ist eine herausforderung aber als
gemeinschaft sind wir nicht allein
ein bild mit einer geschichte der blick
treten ihre haltung ist seine mutter was
was dieser maler es gibt den er zwischen
eltern die ihre kinder einfach nichts
angehen
inga lindström sonntagabend im zdf
[Applaus]
[Musik]